step two
thank you
good evening everybody
um
[Music]
is
your message
please
uh item two decorations of Interest
[Music]
with my brothers I I met what it was uh
thank you chair um
application but I was um
[Music]
I'm sorry
actually for events to receiving the
study segments approves direct record of
the minister amazing healthy science
um
public a maximum 15 minutes from the
United States is submitted in writing to
democratic services
because
I survive this information reports to
consider reports without a financial
government
[Music]
s these applications for permission to
do that they would die on the jetted
side
of the United States
a process you could say in this case the
items introduced by membrane
foreign
[Music]
mission
yes
this intention is the attention to
Suffocation is to enable the
applications
which is the conditions
foreign
[Music]
transforms
the Jews scored only eight for a
possible 25 marks on his own
processments but the 16 billion minutes
everybody looking across and effectively
participated by your school as a
musician
foreign
[Music]
um
thank you I'll see you later
departments
before I started my speech I wouldn't
just like to say that the documents that
were passed around that have been
withdrawn
um would give a 500 impression of the
tree and the description was led by and
was currently and I would hope that the
at least the image of the tree could be
shared with the community
anyway here I am tonight because this
application is quite simply wrong
this application on the face of it seeks
to remove the tree
in reality this application seeks to
overturn a legitimate recent decision by
this committee
a decision by knowing to court to
protect this tree a physician from 12 to
1 to approve the scheme with the true
protected the treat is absolutely
integral to the approval that was
delivered last May
decision
[Music]
the improved speed was probably told
anybody in my view the extension is a
carbon called it's too big it gives an
emission of fatally advised necessity to
have obscure windows on the front
elevation of a bedroom or the bathroom
an example of which I had never seen the
light of in my travels around traffic
from the road it will work as though the
window is always brought it up to have
this on such a beautiful road is wrong
it shouts out design failure
that way they'll cause his heart
I believe that is like that because this
extension is simply too much too big and
overlooking
but that design heart is an attempt to
cover up by which day to be overlooking
into the poses on number 22. however
I do accept that aspect of The Debaters
in the past but my point is in raising
it if you cycle is the vital role of the
tree
the tree apart from being a beautiful
tree especially in the in lutherans will
provide some very welcome respite from
the dominant extension facing veteran
Windows of another 22.
we know construction methods are
possible to build close to a protective
tree
surely it isn't accustomed South
Africans for yourself to pursue the
demise of the tribute
back to that boat that's madly and this
disgraceful maneuverative thoughts that
committee decision I really do see this
as a watershed moment
officers seem to have their hands down
because of previous recommendations
and this makes it appear as though they
support its course of action
I'm sure that they are also likely to
protect committee decisions
My Hope Is that offices are not crazy
enough to control it anymore than they
are advised to but they are actually
resisting this assault on the Democracy
of this town hall this road authority
I stretch the word Authority because it
does not seem to be recognized by the
applicant
planning decisions are delegated to this
committee by this Council this council
is made up of 63 elected members who
represent the whole Borough they entrust
this committee
to the making of robust recipients
the committee did just that in May
last year and I'm truly implore this
committee to hold it certainly aligned
some say
some may say that the applicant will win
this on appeals that is not a reason to
abandon the principle another reason to
consuming against a strong research
committee decision especially where
nothing material has changed I don't
accept the reports assertion that the
arboriculture is decision about the
treatment is material because it is part
of the applicant's voice he wrote about
that decision by the armor or a
culturalist
[Music]
it still is our decision they will
depend we will defend if you appeal
a courage of our conviction that is more
important than the Specter of losing at
the next stage
we did not have to presuppose an appeal
or even a long centipedal but if we wish
to factor it in what we can consider is
that any future inspector would surely
have to take into account a robust
Community debate last May with a firm
decision made the colored hopefully by a
strong defense again today and the sound
reasons for returning the trip
for me in many respects Plumbing
Community Remains the last Sebastian of
true local governments and local
democracy
decisions are made after a good debate
they are not made to love party quotes
for lives and a lot of common sense is
spoken heard and recognized and taken
into account they have all heard such
debates frequently industry tonight the
decision your decision is crucial in the
tree and the residents of number 22 but
it is also vital to prevent a use of
devices to thought the decision of a
legally constituting committee this
community the opportunity thank you
before you start a clock away we've got
a problem here we've submitted some
extra information in a timely manner a
few days ago we found our portability
this afternoon
[Music]
a disadvantaged talk about I don't think
you love me
know the information machine
so if you want to take a few minutes
I've asked Mrs Collins to look through
the information which you simply let us
no no we didn't submit it late
um
[Music]
well I will speak with it
now
good evening ladies and gentlemen I'm
the owner of 22 problem shakes I'm here
to object to the requested there in the
tunnel constant
published in 789 granted in May 22.
as some of the developers reviews Upon A
Commission in 2001 the location of the
windows and the general size and mass of
the building the book two are still very
relevant and the removal of the tree
will have a severe impact onto people
like number 22. the tree the tree
provides screening as stated by the tree
office in February
from 12th of May in this building the
committee refused the planning
permission to allow the filling of one
number three
and the building content as it would be
an invite invasion of the privacy on
number 22 bundle chase the fact that the
loss of the tree would help on the
street scene and deceiving was made by
committee members to vote to keep the
oak tree
the committee then was presented with a
second scheme where by tree one would
not be prepared but retained and
protected by conditions that were to be
written by the truck and the officers in
a robust manner
the English members of the committee
raised concerns that once upon a
commission was granted reactive
difference
comparatory that's what's happened
plumbers and the council legal advisors
told the committee they would look into
the legalities of such planning consent
but the conditions attached to ensure
the retention of the tree was indeed
guaranteed 15 minutes later the funders
announced
quality consent good conditions would
Trump the TPO approval that was what the
committee was told
with the provision of sort of
information provided by trafford's old
head of departments the team
the mass majority of the committee
proceeded to vote with the revised
application and Grant planning position
based on the retention opportunity one
this was democratically voted by the
majority of the committee importantly
now we find ourselves here again
I respect for the University committed
to some by the 12th and may decision
because what happens
is based on both
inaccurate information to suit the
developer regarding the actual true
condition of tree one
As I Shall prove to you three solutions
report
was sent to the Agricultural Society the
governing body the CEO examined the
report and concluded it to be accurate
the extent of this letter a copy of this
letter historically the planning process
has been continuously hindered by the
applicant and developer they need to
correctly sort of not compound
application and information required by
the document validation checklist
you have to be providing the highly
inaccurate tree report by tree Solutions
it's on 12 months after filing the
application
has led to numerous problems the report
was used by Trafford funders informing
their opinion on the tree however we
have provided two number independent
tree reports that provide the true and
honest reflection between team one those
authorizations
[Music]
as you will see from our presentation
part there is photograph showing the
construction work activities only three
days after concept was granted
developers breached the contracts that
reached certainly said their names
[Music]
just absolute clarity
that was the end of your contributions
convincing now that the locals are
plastic between the uh Nebraska
community
[Music]
yeah
it is uh Mr globe in the group
foreign
[Music]
tone through the statute police
and comments on that once you give your
um but obviously I'm entitled in
representing the applicant to understand
what papers before the community and
which Miss Cody might use to assist in
her representations for you because yeah
thank you
tree you want to say that through using
poor conditioning and indeed has been
granted consent for its removal in 2015.
the consent which have implemented
this application is not uh
condition tree
in the determines final compromise
petitions were imposed on the planned
version for the extension importantly at
no point was it suggested that the
retention of the tree was when
protection of makers immunity protection
of the tree was based on a possible wide
open
if you look at the reasons for the
petition don't think 75 or 77 of these
reported reference and make General
protection of community there is no part
of the representation
protection Community too
the train is not in a good condition and
my client is now secular position to
remove it
and reaching that decision your
specialist offices really should pay you
for the price here were able to review
information provided both by the client
and by the local fire protection too
that is why at age 79 of your real
report that's why pay some retirement
report is wrong in terms of medical
comments the decision relating to the
tree and the Fallout for you has total
regards to all various information
provided from the tree from all parties
the same part of the report says the
conditions have already been breached
they have not and your enforcement
officers have confirmed this case
they're on site the day after a last day
contractor turned up to the business
the opposite note in that paragraph 10
tree is still there
are 14 the tree has limited life
expectancy and a wider immunity can be
better
my climate has no issue with replacing
me exactly as your opposite require
species size and rotation
so let's hurt the conclusion of
paragraph 27 of those report the tree
has never been seen as critical to make
development accessible
is in any case in a condition which does
not support retention but through a
condition of the planning permission and
attachment is actually moving kind of
revised conditions now proposed a new
and more appropriate species to treat
can be planted let's serve the immediate
to the area which is the basis for the
illusion through the preservation
thank you
I was just very grateful when I was what
we've had there is a
uh the other comments introduction to
the application which were set by Mr
healing uh
said
um
without slowly through the reports
abortion of course
um
sorry
good
two of those exceptions today are
unconsciousness
which again says obviously
um
previous classification
over the course
um
foreign
[Music]
and uh I have to say
I was not impressed by the tree that was
talking about this evening and to be one
such a bus has been made large tree I
see no benefit whatsoever in that tree
and
I don't believe it's removal or I sort
of significant impact on 122.
the pictures actually I have to see
praise him if you land because in the
flesh is non-attractive tree at all I
think in the report it said it's really
crop back okay and not very well I mean
that's that's
all so I have no issue so it's true
being removed and you think being
planted and all the neighbors have
obviously got very
at his head about this and it's a big
issue for
their differences are not the reason for
this committee to make decisions there
are differences between soiled from
South Africa
be removed
and so the building where you can go for
our treasure it and a new trades
um
[Music]
excuse me
um
previously on the previous application
and I think the two positions has stated
I thought about it there is nothing that
has changed since we made by decision
previously the medicine for the right
reasons
about that at the time we impose these
two conditions for the reasons first
stated you know before and I hope that
those reasons will change so I'll walk
around until we're now doing complete
180 this is regarding everything that we
said previously and pretending the
previous meeting didn't exist it did so
uh I I can't see these things change in
terms of the actual three arms
foreign
[Music]
uh you know I mean what happens is we
start by our decision again this evening
six months for another
another application the exact same uh
people with us tonight you know it's a
bit like a year because
you're supposed to uh yeah
again
so I think our decision previously was
perfectly acceptable I never thought
for the last time I know that these
stickies
the application I'm precisely the same
Brands a lot not confused we refuse to
amend our previous academic uh and said
to our previous decision because our
previous decisions
thank you
um
in this instance
the uh to the
um
[Music]
more than 100
of our cultural officer that I've come
back with uh and the lifestyle that she
doesn't mind
[Music]
that we could leave the office's
decision
[Music]
um
so I found this quite confusing
and watched the main economies were
integrated on this particular version
for however
and watch that
and we've gone into the food
preservation order on
a tree
I know
it's
it's like
without talking about actually that was
a true personality
and that I don't understand
why I'm doing that is it just so like
questions
if so what's the purpose of your
presence
yes
quite a large area and it says we report
that within such a large area it is
[Music]
to make that assessment so if you
understand don't disagree with us
[Music]
thank you
apologies
that it says
[Music]
my understanding
um
[Music]
in order to do as much of it because
absolutely applications
[Music]
agreed to previously and then I've got
to see how we can
go against
um this is a really
great sentence is is
[Music]
but
and the fact is that we looked at this
and I remember it and I don't understand
a lot last time
[Music]
are we
thank you very much
[Music]
it sounds
like the residents currently unless you
know the rest was about 10 years ago
after example of Satan and this this was
10 years ago away with all this
design of an extension was was brought
forward so I think the beginning of the
treatment
of the president's feet and the Olympics
[Music]
or something
creepy between the amount of competition
out
and that's really Administration
[Music]
I also agree with what um says
and it's real um
foreign
and forward against
your emotion is
always
[Music]
right yeah all right
recommendation
[Music]
so if you want to refuse the application
you can keep playing that
some of that board please and if you
were to approve the application
and now we will take the promotion in
which direction although she wishes to
go live officer accommodation
so
all else we should go against those
recommendation
[Music]
um
the site is found by residential
neighbors to the East and North across
the south of the car park and off this
building
so the West has gone by himself
alongside the longest broken hearts
the first drama is the replacement of
the existing time
which will incorporate the cable group
to the main parts
with a featured vehicle and two bombs
facing west
North facing front porch
to the South
and Eastern across the north would be a
parking area where the driveway could
see the cars and ceramics
the driver would accommodate three
bedrooms with two of us
as a university of imaginative
properties
the objections in summary relate to
immunity impacts upon Neighbors from
loss of life's privacy and overbearing
impact foreign
Springfield Road to the east
and upgradable assistance
happens
um just looking at the problems
yeah first
um
proposal
so this is
[Music]
um
that this this plant shows
community
um the previous proposal source
of the
um
the same comparisons
foreign
[Music]
do you feel sleepy
or that can help work with with Thomas
is to reach
this reduces the
other person was not sure any five years
supply of 1001 that social parts
supplies
under construction with no adverse
impacts or significant demonstrate
are the law is considered to comply with
the results
first
[Music]
um
thank you thank you
nobody's challenges in this building
shouldn't be demolished and retailed
there are good Arguments for modernizing
and improving this small formula however
this will be the third application on
this site and each is trying to impose
an inappropriate to still read your own
the last application is going to the
thing had a very clear main issue cited
by the inspector it was the effect on
the living conditions of the occupied
that may bring weddings namely the
mountains at that moment on Springfield
close
but not much has changed immunity
these Gardens smoke away from government
property and and to exacerbate the
issues of massive and Sidelines in these
properties were sit within the Old
Market Conservation Area
has a planning inspectorism inspectively
murdered the retaining rules due to a
changing levels are significantly taller
on the Springfield roadside it's
important to recognize that this area
was brought into the Old Market
constellation
hello in 2014 it provides important
guidance
in 3.7 of the account which talks about
residential extensions and alterations
policy 46 is very good extensions which
alter the former matching of groups from
residential dwellings will not be
permitted this application is pretty
much the same height as the 2818
application and only a little smaller
than the 2021 scheme which will most
confused
the residents of Springfield Road one to
seven will be emptied further the side
Bonds on their replays will be explored
removing the town escape and the church
and other features in the distance
instead a two-story block
3.8 of the camera where it talks about
streets getting on the topic run has a
clear aim to preserve key views within
into and out of the Conservation Area
policy 68 there's traffic Council will
work in partnership with Community to
inform new development within the
conservation area the residents of
Springfield Road feel they are not being
listened to and they will have their
Sidelines taken
access in and out of the property are
also destroyed especially when reversing
the NHA report explains no footwears or
pedestrian walkways are provided at this
location and as such The Pedestrian
walking kit will do so in the
carriageway and without the provision of
any segregation facility or protection
from plastic vehicles
directly opposite and the lha go one
step further
if the local Highway Authority it is
accepted that the proposed development
vehicle access relations are not ideal
and if you go back to the 2017 planning
application refusal might just it was
clear the site would lead to potential
conflict between Highway users when
carrying out Maneuvers to the detriment
of Highways and pedestrian safety
concrete acrossly helpful nothing just
changed here
thank you conclude this is an
application is just a variation on two
previously reviewed applications I
thought the planning committee didn't be
consistently and stand by the principles
of protecting conservation and
residential immunity there are still
present highway safety issues and they
asked this committee to refuse this
application thank you
um
[Music]
thank you
counselors
the neighbors do not accept development
of the property in the format keeping
this current maps
goldmark has been identity under its
parallel mission for seven years
in 2019 which was granted they could
take the cabbage and height of the
existing with minimal impact and
surrounding properties and the
cultivation area the neighbors would get
to the criminal application
the committee refused to do floor
applications January 2018 due to Leslie
had impact on the need to take highways
and conservations the committee also
refused to do for our application in
2021 for negative impact in low Central
immunity and this was all held by the
planning inspector who stated that due
to massive and proximity they would be
significant hold of the different
conditions because they bring much about
it the reason for reviews will remain
insane the application is higher than
that refused in 2018 and the same wind
and south of Houston Trace 21 the mass
of the elevation is facing
what is currently a small group there's
lots of the neighbors will be first from
two bedroom to bathroom three storage
enemies the region is seven meters
and proximity have not been overcome as
it cannot be overcome it's a small sign
it's on a hill it's in guarded anything
it's not suitable for due for cocktail
which is three stores rather big three
stories relative to our patio due to the
hill when viewed from our patio the
output wants to stop the equivalent of
two double decker buses on top of each
other on a site that's just over the
half the width of the folding attic or
cricket page relatively it's two and a
half times besides of the the wall the
height difference is the average 18
factor and the close side team with the
inspectorate pointed out due to the help
you already feel like we're at the
bottom of the pole and the inspector
acknowledge that this will be like
putting a lid on that hole it's an
inbuilt site the distance is to have a
bit habitable winds and surrounding
houses are far short of the guidelines
the development has Windows and major
actual booms which allows their website
direct sight line into surrounding
properties the living room has double
doors that look directly into Microsoft
room other family houses with small
children and safe gardening should be
considered I'm extremely concerned that
highways is not matching current
guidelines or the mpps the limitations
of the existing are not applicable and
standards have been superseded to help
pedestrians
in summary the new proposal is still
over preparing is still intrusive
it will result in significant loss of
privacy and there's a hedge Community it
will be overlooked by Windows farther
below distance guidelines with our
life-sided to Children's values the
president took race on the highways
alive
and we hope that you exercise your Sound
Treatment as you did on two previous
occasions and refuse on sound planning
grounds
thank you
foreign
Conservation Area
I hope you agree with this indication
the comparison of the existing proposed
drawings in the submission that you've
seen
the skin replaces a an existing
environmental over the world designed
with features including vertical sliding
such Windows slate tiles
compartments including the seal results
in terms of the impact on the music of
residents of Springfield though a number
of the changes have been made since the
earlier earlier a fair decision to
address this issue and I would prefer
news now I think that some points were
made earlier but it's not going to
change
so firstly the height is 1.1 meters
lower than the previous scheme and
indeed the richest now feel lowly which
of the houses on Springfield Road
whereas in the previous thought that the
officer report describes the proposed as
being significantly lower than the
majority of buildings in the locality
secondly the ridge is also two meters
further away from the rear of the
properties on Springfield Road further
reducing the impacts and it's now
between 26 and 28 meters away from the
real relations
there's only a sight line drawing which
you've seen has been submitted showing
the news from the rear of the properties
on Springfield Road and comparing
existing dwellings with geography the
impact of the reductions to the to the
steam is very clearly demonstrated in
the drawing
both religious and Boundary Waters
retained will continue to provide
screening definitely only ground floor
windows are proposed on the elevation
bases perhaps things and these are set
back from the boundary and no window
Space Systems are available
just close to the boundary
your officers reported assesses the
impact on residential immunity in
considerable detail it concludes the
proposal wouldn't have any unacceptable
impact on residential immunity previous
reasons
and suddenly therefore the student
provides an enhancements of the
character of the conservation area by
replacing the existing uninspiring
dwelling with a well-designed building
and achieved this without harm to the
residential community of nearby
properties
I hope therefore you will support your
office recommendation and throughout the
Planning Commission accordingly
foreign
this is
unfortunately improved proposal over the
last one I think that there is still an
amazing problem with it and that is that
the roof is extremely wide
as well as I uh it's basically less High
than it was before
but it's the width of the concern over
them and always being in these um
applications
compared with the sites as it is a
present the site is perfect for a moment
and when you know when we are
repeatedly told that they're making
amendments to take into account the
concerns that we've had before when this
has been rejected and be rejected over
here as well
um you know
they haven't gone as far as considering
a single-story building of course they
don't have to so everybody's no right
but they're not the Asian physics but
it's also our right to keep on refusing
them when effectively the same thing is
happening it's a big wide group area
which says to tracks through the
residential immunity
due to its massing and proximity to the
housing options
governments that is my current view
um I'll be interested to hear what the
uh
foreign
thank you chairman
um
it is a difficult one this is
the levels sort of
exacerbates the problem it's difficult
to argue with growth
and I'm looking at the museums for
refusalem page 96 and it's time to get a
couple of time for your old Rich at
least if we overcome I'm not entire
certainly without a Canadian
uh I think all three of those reasons
existed uh
impacts as well all Sam which of them
could be honestly standing and say ah
well that used to be the case
so therefore that would be super refusal
is out
um
all three uh I don't know it says but
still standing for from previous
applications yes
but that's about the best you would
possibly say about it it's less bad is
it acceptable
would you want it there if you if you
were one of the existing of them will
you be I always try to be when I'm
looking at it how would I feel if it was
meant to pull ourselves
is difficult
to say that it wouldn't be able to
understand
the differences
so it does make it very difficult to see
I mean if those cancer supports and also
brings up yesterday I have the right to
uh applications
will be alone
architectural genius that it has somehow
found a way to put two stories on our
site without causing any problems with
these designs I look forward to that to
their arise
um but given the circumstances
and given the design from this it is
[Music]
that are making this so problematic okay
because if it was not flat level site
from underneath
then perhaps we will really say well now
we've changed the entire responsibly the
area of this hobby but we can't do that
that's impossible
so given the circumstances and given the
previous inspections that's the comments
previously
I don't see how it brought with faith
this application fixes the problems
based previously as I said I valuelessly
pause on page 96 and I would ask people
who of mind is to vote you know
recommendation on which of those reasons
for refusal have been resolved and in
what way do you argue that that is
understood
again just returning professional once
School wasn't but it was previously I
can't tell you about this for the
reasons that is that one I don't believe
the previous problems have been resolved
and I I'm struggling to see how it's
experience
the brilliant solution but that would be
the first uh assuming slowly busy like
well I will be the first bit of voting
code where if someone comes up it's such
a wonderful idea and I would love to see
that but I don't see how it could either
so on Instagram
so I will I'll I'll push things along
and I will personally
feeds the application the opposition is
[Music]
Customs
um
I think it's a Well thoughts out I'll be
used in line with geography
[Music]
to
the properties next door they'll have a
similar
distance between Springfield and that
wall by building
um I think this is sympathetic to
be designed to to what
is there already a modernization is not
a true story but I think it's one story
about it
anyway uh parking and the traffic
the regards
of people in government that already in
the road is
your objection and that's a that's a
good name
it is a due to cancer drive to ensure
that the relations
honestly
[Music]
um
that was a lot of mentioned earlier
about visiting some platform because you
can't aspects from suicides our Google
Maps but sometimes you really have to do
that I I I I remember visiting
Springfield Road
um the first application came and it is
one of the dramatic
um views the way you just change your
opinion
my garden
um
[Music]
it's just my personal view is I don't
think this can Sports any building this
hike
is it true story probably the definition
could be one and a half story now maybe
um
it is a higher roof
um and the angle is a really difficult
site but the angle of the building is a
longitudinal
um
which means that the impact of that
route is is disproportionate to those
God names don't have any impact on
Springfield Road and so I I just can't
see I mean in terms of improvements
I love Schools
closings and comparison to abusive
um
[Music]
related but obviously in all the parts
make it
let's be sure to Stores
um
response
uh when I regret the report and I know
the area is where I used to work the
building
completely soft I expected to go there
and see
certificates development but after he
goes to the Cycles vehicles I think that
this is a good use of the size of honey
it doesn't matter if Joseph
Council functions
recognition
the experience of my colleagues so
again I've been mentioning the whole
behind the previous application
as through business at all I don't
understand it so I'm
I just want to thank you to explain it
because this is this is Allah and and
they are I think my colleagues are never
been here against a highly and and
there's no difference between the
previous application and the
multiplication
[Music]
yeah
a number of different comparisons that
can be made because this is the third
application we've got the existing
drawing as well
uh so so
it's 1.4 Which is higher than the
existing division of performance is
higher than the existing on the road
um but it doesn't projects that also
existed on those projects right to the
back of the cycle direct itself
um in terms of comparison with
[Music]
um
the late the last previous refusal
um the rich life without really being
7.8
meters or 7.5 meters so it will now be
1.1 into the lower
than that previously on that which would
be stepped further away from the Eastern
doubly of the site the Lord being 1.
Romney's below
further away from
that boundary
um in relation to the 2018 scheme
um
this proposal would be marginally
higher than that scheme but that was a
flat rate of divine
um and it was within 2.5 meters of the
boundary of the rear boundary where
we've done this bridge because obviously
stepped along my way from the boundary
it's like 9.4 meters away from that
boundary so it doesn't really compare
with the 2016
um
I don't know if that helps to
uh
it is very much I mean it means it is
not one for the kitchen and because
it's not really dense populous New Year
and he just said and he's abiding level
um
the officer segmentation
we have to
relax
um
[Music]
this week but before we do could I just
remind numbers that this is already
accepted with the previous City that
there's no harmless harmful from a
repetitive play and there's no Heritage
of this type of character in the
character Remains the Same so
um it would be extremely unreasonable
because it's a reimbursed Reasons from
the 2017 which has been found exclusive
and that inspectors and that's um
foreign
[Music]
our example certain code is is
a flat size which isn't then you
wouldn't have the issue but they both
they don't belongs expression
yeah
is
[Music]
that allows you more stupid components
for office of recommendation
and now the reverse motion although she
wants to protect the report
thank you
guys
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
thank you
certain things
I guess that's fine
obviously I guess after recommendations
[Music]
probably
stop working this one's up too many
miles
um
is there's not so many plans it's not a
science issue it's not so high
and then we do the same because you the
same reasons
[Music]
it's the only reason I was just because
that's why the accountability suggested
three reasons
if I see those books
into size scale or massive and then
to remove
commission three that's on 96.
and in terms
are unreasonable
I heard
that heritage
the cycling scale must be connected to
his husband too
by a certain reason more than their
marriage charms
because
okay so summarize
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
development
this request was declines development
violency on the cost of the possible to
test by a service charge this position
is accepted by offices and is expanded
against the report and will also refer
them as a specification report which
demonstrates that there's only 280 from
77 pounds of access from the series
which is
a thousand pounds
profit marketing expectations
considerations
[Music]
along with this
standards literary first impacts and
develops have been identified the
outcomes a significantly enough to the
design of the scheme to the office of
aspirations for high quality design to
provide the emergency
signs
[Music]
foreign
thank you
this game has challenged
we don't believe that
all of the issues have been adequately
addressed and we think that there's
three very important issues which lead
further consideration by the 2017
highways and parking
immediately to the north of the
applicant site we will see that there
will be above field has a series of
traffic coming measures and also traffic
regulation orders which consist of it's
exactly outlines and also how many
airlines to quite consuming distance
traffic calmly measures and traffic
regulation orders are therefore reasons
and that's because there are high risks
Associated by the hybrids Department
the traffic that's not using that
environment
in
2018-19 a child with school child was
knocked off a bicycle on the very corner
of Bradfield unconditional Avenue which
is a very access point that the
applicant performance to bring in up to
22 number additional vehicles that will
potentially reside on what it is
but it's severe congestion in this area
all the time
sorry there's severe congestion in this
area around pickup and drop-off times of
the students but for example's Catholic
college and Highfield primary schools in
the South there's a alternative Circle
bus Germany circle at the Saint Anthony
Southwick College have to come off at
collection time to the evenings to stop
having to parking there
[Music]
be
parking provision 22 number Vehicles we
also believe is inadequate we have
reached in foreign
cars that are um to support the
occupants that are there such as like a
conclusion of public transporting gaming
with lots of 18 Apartments proposals I
don't believe that turning 22 car
parking spaces including three disabled
will be adequate are so similarly in the
Ash Street Parking side of no street
parking is particularly poor and I think
that it will lead to significant
problems in the area should uh should
the student go out in the development
intensity it could probably
um
our major issue is an issue which then
the authorities yet to deal with are
fields
and that's the right of way to do where
on the premises you can see on the page
20 seconds agents the main planning
document at the cycle plant of the
property is the rights of way there
Council and the authority today we'll
say they are not here to do with private
rights of way because one thing for this
place in mind is private right of way
was was reinforced by the piano
the application
foreign
[Music]
and and that's really that that's the
end of the demands
um
this is
actually investigated the position is
very simply as follows
uh
no rightful certainly assertion of a
variety of way but right away arising uh
existence
the only righteous way that does exist
was Reserve to the benefits of the
council when it's social science in 1992
the objector does not have the benefits
of that right away
according to the applicant's owner so my
advice to committee is upon can ignore
public any representations would still
get to make difficult disaster assertion
of writing way as regards this science
is so far to concerns him treatment
[Music]
I guess you also don't feel alone
it sets out through your officers
location essential accessibility is
peace services
it's an ideal location for residential
development to help people have housing
needs and relieve the development
pressure and more sensitive science
across the bride
but those departments would be developed
and managed by airwell Valley homes
which no longer establish strategist
minor that owners and manages around
2000 homes for classic native Manchester
region
traffic is a priority Development Area
for everyone running now currently
implementing multi-million pound lead
generation program but it's our West
estate
units
[Music]
the affordable events for the 18
Department to propose would be Captain
America housing violence and this means
that the rent will not exceed benefits
available for housing from the
government and will provide for homes
that actually will be affordable this is
in line with over a college level policy
and our social purpose as I said
September 22 about 7 40035 applicants on
the Trafford housing Manchester 27 but
we have to continue the two bedroom
property
contribution it's amazing their needs
the application has been launched with
the authority since 2020 they've been
extensive discussions with the officers
throughout the process and the schemes
from such as several changes to adjust
the requirements of offices and external
casualties
the offices of activated strongly for
amazing design standards through the
process and the outcomes a high quality
treatment abuse requirements sets out
through the traffic examinated
before who when Apartments will be far
from the United England through the
21-26 for 100 applications
to enable the scheme to control quickly
they don't exceeds housing and quietly
within astounding accommodation and the
size of the individual environments this
is a sugar ready scheme on the ground
field site that are much needed
affordable housing group is already
underway well underway and dischargeable
development conditions with anticipating
the scheme will be complete about 24
next year
given the boys affordable housing needs
and high qualities and secured by the
emphasis without the introduction
officers
this evening just in terms of Mr Price
comments have been covered that's very
comprehensively and committee report by
the highways Authority mail offices by
the applicants transport Specialists
Edward Valley is in that it's a similar
schemes and similar locations
[Music]
it's really about around
um
local housing allowance and the
different different
social house
actually is
moonstone local housing allowances it
needs discounts at the so if you get
political housing benefits
for a new accommodation
affordable housed affordable event is
accommodation in theory can be eighty
percent of market value
and and so on which the providers being
provided for them at 80 percent of the
market value
um obviously
[Music]
a Captain Underpants which means
whatever those people get in Social
benefits because then doesn't exceed
another
[Music]
whereas this ensures that
anybody
that's great
um
[Music]
in the absence of any um form of it
being used as a pizza which clearly
isn't the case for this one I'm really
really fast and happy with it even
though we have something isn't that your
affordable but
[Music]
um
required for people that are clearly
struggling and I think that this is this
is because
the parking 22 spaces for 18 Flats
um
[Music]
on this site and and yes
thank you
thank you uh
um
[Music]
I like classification from Offices
please I've checked
my concern is there's one staircase
if there was a fire in them I wear
everything
that's the staircase
the people to
the right would have no idea
[Music]
and that deeply concerns me there's no
there's only one staircase
[Music]
thank you
it says that if it's too close
issue
um we're very concerned
um and we would expect the building
regulations to operate properly and we
do not make money decisions
regulation of operating Association so
relationships
be a specific information
um
foreign
[Music]
it's not really I think on page nine
first of the high quality beautiful and
Sustainable Building high quality you
belongs
I think you'd have to have um
yeah it's beautiful in the same way
[Music]
the the fact that it's ugly isn't really
as Solutions
so I'll go along with the office of
recommendationally experience
um
alcohol
I must agree with Mr pan you spoke
against the application around the
highways issues that certainly it's a
school time you can see be very very
hectic on that field but that is a
similar situation in many many parts of
our forum and um
I think what those battleships before
was very genuine but that would be a
reason to send an application now
because our phones that we wish it
didn't people do like to drive to
schools or children not special for Just
Cause havoc in their home that's not the
reason
I'm happy in the application and all the
members have talked and you've shared
explained about the cost of living there
and how that is very much more
reasonable than in other places where it
is what you need accommodation you need
in the board and I thank you very much
represents me towards this evening
results
[Music]
a few category so we say about each side
election growth
said she has waited access to the car
park is a thriving actual home school
just on the other side of the road where
there is a concert around for buses
there's uh so
I of course announces which is 9 900 to
a thousand children in that school
Portugal or going into the museum
for us to after school obviously depends
there's also a long Healthcare headset
for that while you're attracted to
another parking is working in Africa
does that do you think that all people
are those also concerns about two
disciples and what is my opinion that's
not going to happen there are six
disabled
converging parts of the amount of War
for the previous message to that uh
three disabled parking spaces
by half
uh the question in the writing way
obviously has been explained out to us
if we are pushing off access to the
properties
um I'm not going to propose refusal for
what I'd only be saying is that I will
buy a Tunnels for us in this view uh
the fact that we need houses
registration to to clients in my opinion
so I I'm not going to reverse against
them certainly would like to support the
application thank you
moment
and we supporting us
um but I am disappointed not to see
um
discrimination against the wheelchair
users and
um not just have a choice to be able to
be on any of yourself
think about
everybody's choice
yes
um
[Music]
but
foreign
[Music]
yeah so actually by keeping the number
of parking spaces in
development
you actually
give people less incentive to open a
second you can't or any car at all and
therefore you know and therefore that's
how we restrict the traffic issues okay
and guess if there is important what
that is for the council to sort of not
for the afternoon
um
two original features of this available
in America and one is their Equity
between the trainings as my colleagues
that have been depending a brand new
version not just a centralized as well
he has explained uh very good thank you
uh
in better future
you can see here because in traffic
there are hundreds of those applications
so we have a problem also in this
environment and and thank you very much
for this uh for this project
thank you John I want to a person think
that um
is
if so several 17 of the population that
are disabled
um what most people if more people
become disabled and number one disabled
so
any family any of you friends
with that super top
um
don't become disabled you're gonna have
to move
how do you get out
if there's an earth in the building
and
we need to take a stand are we actually
serious about our buildings our host
people being accessible
are already playing your service
and
I'm really struggling with the concept
of creating something that denies me
because it's
it's not an accessibility
um
[Music]
and hated it because people would knock
on my window
we need to let them into the building
so I I wouldn't Choose the ground floor
but I've made
within it for the last I won't be able
to get to my home or come out from home
this
because the message yes
[Music]
she decided
of the people that are whose Fighters
possibilities
that's a lot of my immunity to be like
but of course like possibly or seven
pound points a week as you just
explained
we do have to make some honest people of
power disabled in this country in this
world
[Music]
this kind of property is Affordable
wonderful
well
I need my scrap transport so we've been
so excited against this we need to make
sure that the affordable property is
important for everybody
[Music]
um
I struggled with response it was
assault five times without the source a
lot of questions over the last few days
to work because I also struggle with
this because
it's been some great work you know my
designs
on the ground floor
um
[Music]
it's not just about the top two before
not being accessible to support disabled
people
characteristics people that smell of uh
virtual discussions
and I accepted all the arguments around
the Auditors and housing and if the
complicated population is used
to go along with that
I would get all of that but it still
comes down to if that's a castle Proctor
says if um she wants to visit some
relatives should come there
I think the same position as the the uh
we cannot carry on doing because we
cannot carry on a freely inaccessible
amount
investment
and
[Music]
um
so thank you chair and um yeah I I I'm
sure it matters you'll appreciate
concerns that's being expressed about
accessibility it was really just
criticized that
um the committee has to determine
applications as you know in in the light
of our own planning courses and also in
respect of uh national public policy
guidance and certainly I'm sure many
would wish that the national picture was
rather different than it is we do have
the opportunity to seek
um uh higher standards of accessibility
but the government is very clear that
the route that we do that is through our
local plan and that's the way that if
there are concerns around that sort of
being expressed this evening that that's
how you can influence
um
the the this issue and you can secure
um higher standard student local plan
but obviously once that plan is adopted
you can apply them within plan decisions
uh as they are this evening but in terms
of this application here and now those
policies aren't in place and so
therefore I must encourage you to
determine application in the height of
what is before you and in terms of the
current policies
yeah thank you uh Council Thompson
council department
that's
[Music]
is that
being
discriminated against in terms of access
to your property and having the same
rights to live and renting affordable
Properties or pull out a skyscrapers
that are all built like the leading the
tower
discrimination
surely that is
a loss of residential leadership or a
person
perspective of their disability of
accessing the property we are actively
through immunity for lack of energy
sovereign
foreign
[Music]
going on
for more than 18 months now and we met
her
and certainly when I first came into
this committee last night
uh I am a sustainable journey of being
frustrating but I believe as a committee
we want to developers to build accessory
values we want allow us to build
lifetime homes to Lifetime standards
yes
we can't do it because
we still don't have a local plan
that incorporates the customer report
and we need that
last week
so I I would like to have the businesses
and how much longer are we going to have
to wait before it's a place thank you
thank you
[Music]
but if it was a system committee would
be very glad to take an update on the
comparison plans as you know hey um
[Music]
my own thoughts on this is
three years now and I've realized some
progressions
[Music]
is inaccessible
um
we have the proposal on the table we
accept this
um recommendation
time to seven
more advanced
um suggested this meeting is
[Music]
and I have no idea
not next
because the genuine has jumped back on
he gets down to the chair I'll have the
word yeah
um
[Music]
thank you
yes thank you thank you
yeah
[Music]
um
galaxies foreign
[Music]
um
after something
these days
so the next item is 18 Digital Drive
the parties
thank you
however an issue story was constructed
as a result of an application to try
approval for a project sanction which is
the 13th of Singapore patient
Factory
[Music]
the current application is the student's
very sideway extension
the details within the report the
application was submitted last May and
may be valid and his name is 105 that
the applications subsequently made
invalid and because it came to like the
Oak Ridge extension had not been
constructed and therefore with the
upward extension and the decided where
we have to be considered together it was
therefore made invalid the local
expansion is now what we've classes
substantially complete and therefore the
application has come back inside of her
expansion as a separate building
operation
those six objections have been received
the current application and the
application is also according to
committed by Council votes in support of
the local governments
medicines you see do relate to the input
extension which is not such a
disapplication however there were also
objection phrase about the process
several applications to get to this
position
in addition to see the objections and
design scale impacting accuracy advice
and consultation process
across the frustrations through the
planning process on those devices
we must assess the application propose
considering application after photos is
considered single story extension of an
appropriate design scale with property
and do not present past Humanity to our
computer and therefore such as the
conditions as departmental
reports could be recommend approval
so this is the just to show you this is
the um
the property as existing
for the Post light part
this is the proposal
the Blue Line run the signing version
which has been hit and flat roof and
slightly material
this is the top speed and
complete
and this is an application that was um
previously brewed by Tennessee last year
requires vehicle expansion being
completed
my name is today
[Music]
thank you three minutes
thank you
[Music]
thank you all right so I'm speaking of
half of my mother and all the neighbors
listening
which hasn't been mentioned by the
planet of the server if you're a must
responsiveness this is a street
components
[Music]
over the last two years the applicant
has Relentless Resort it's developed a
large two-story house and a contact like
he said he's the only problem
there's been several applications and
seven different sets of times and over
this period of time which is
over here between 50 objections I
believe it's existing and as you know in
the recent king of speech and if there's
two things objections to huge
developments as a coming in in their
future legislation you know we could be
negative to be very angry down the
streets against
Unity reported by the black sake
unfortunately as a residents feared and
I remember some of the councils here the
president when I discuss this last time
um
that the applicant is determined to try
and serve with their employment and he
splits across two applications of him
that would never be allowed to do things
listed in things for Coalition in fact
the original occupations the parents and
small it's very first or extension
Design Center hydrates and today
exception similar to this
do that application after receiving a
number of objections and being
informally told by our own planning
officers that this could never be passed
which would help sustainability and the
adverse impact on the labor unionism
since beginning
[Music]
but applying for a simple straight-up
first or extension
and if you did this clearly to try and
separate the whole of the planning
process
through the game reduced by the public
religion this same time
and was brought him between the other
guys as straight to extension but isn't
it enough to know only an effect the
latest application he seeking to achieve
the original proposal of a two-story
house with side and a little extension
by expressing his costumes after
applications the end result will be a
property that's greatly identical and
then decide scale impact as first
application which economists indicated
to refuse and it's actually far larger
than the second attacking applications
basically notice that explicitly
explicitly State it's just reviews
surprisingly applying opposite report
recognizing application should be
improved this Channel and suggests that
policy extension is more distant scale
and proportionate and subservients the
existing octave however I respectfully
respectfully submit that policy of L7 is
the core strategy means that the scale
of this extension aren't distributed and
the context of the property which is
already very significant
okay just one quick fight
okay
thank you
I'm here
um I appreciate the difficulty of
organisms
obviously it was the previous
application
and but this is not an opportunity to
rehash and we fight that battle this
that's happened
now this is about killing the side of
the real extension
it's not about the existing control
in relation to this
how you know he's also not against any
rule of manipulations
in relation to the property that happens
it must be new Governors how many
properties across traffic
yeah
applications
[Music]
in future applications for future works
for this property while we build those
the question is is the existing
applications
[Music]
I whilst I appreciated
in relation to this woman therefore
people
uh
thank you
[Music]
thank you yeah
um
so the road
um this is
[Music]
you get everything we have mixes really
um
and I understand that it is
[Music]
this is too big in itself anyway this
application itself or
um yeah it is the wrong development and
it's somewhere else
so I'll be actually on the other side
that I'll be closing that we would use
the application on balance of scale and
massive
[Music]
um
and the way this this has been done is
added to that failure and and I am very
disappointed about the way outside of
this process but one of those two
structure because I think we were right
to
um
it is already too big and Timmy and has
two big maths given what is next door to
what is it it's surrounded by about
purpose
um and animal to that is just catching
what's your work so I really really
surprised
um
[Music]
sauce
thank you
as this is again
[Music]
um
whether the houses is now is
right in Congress since our lives all of
them is irrespective Society Association
issue those similar to number 16 from
the 14th about Cinema
as such as decide
is it is it
differently again
and he's not and what's different from
other properties uh 14 16.
[Music]
thanks chair
um
be sympathetic to the uh the speaker
early and
that all these characters
[Music]
but we are going back to local bank we
must make a decision and on our hearts
we don't have a wife to do that maybe
decision
foreign
and we can't use the topically it's like
the first presence
some people will be very little an
application
I hear absolutely got resonance about to
say thank you
thank you
certified speaker and I said
one of Constitution and anger among the
so
what would be
emotionally and sympathy is there is
a more happy but
we need to follow the rules
Nation
thank you
[Music]
just to see my opinion after those
performers and it's not because I don't
understand
the arguments that we've told me about
and really seeing the arguments
and I don't think within our rules
I'm sorry baby
to work
um
[Music]
so we've had two proposals you can take
the Russians who refused so what would
you ask the reviews
[Music]
time yes
and it's also it's involved
specifically together
[Music]
the application
should be without protection
you know
and take the opposite proposal that
we've approved
all those events
[Music]
um
next item will be 30 Little Rock Road
thank you chairman the application would
like to do a two-story setting these
hatch case
this is a great bit of proxy with a
touchdown to the rear which connects to
that enabling 128
condition is sought to be Russian single
story rear extension to connect the main
house for the latest attached garage
the mission is also set up the eruption
front porch and conversion of the
existing garage from traditional Revenue
information
the mother's daughter when those in the
Garrison has towards
show an application process to increase
the distance from the extensions
adjustments are boundaries
all the neighboring properties of
Liberty numbers
all issues raising lessons of
representational containments in Camp
where our office is considerably posted
on exceptionally since it's designed an
appearance setbacks of residential
emergency policies
[Music]
foreign
exactly my privacy will be impacted with
the various extension will both come to
my friends and garage the previous
external below from the emergency room
onto the drive will be directly facing
the kitchen window
thirdly I will use any views to the
gardens in the neighborhood how would
you see a brick wall for microchip in
London plans do not address any of the
objection surveys irrational plans
I've prepared the two sets of funds and
find an almost identical the dimensions
measured on the palms
government again there is an absence of
any information about drainage and how
to put up rainwater including sloping
and blood groups are going to be managed
this will impact on my property in
particular my garage room as the two
garages were attached and I shared and
share a commented along that wall
the third point I wish to make
is make it clear that the fans between
number 30 and my house is not shared
events is built entirely mind quality
they will not allow us to be dismantled
through the partly the following today's
construction of the extension and I wish
this female
so you play some markers
you can see
it's
good I'm sure
it has been many many movies
[Music]
applications
this planning application
[Music]
if you replaced 28 Little Rock
a couple of seconds so
with 24 Elmwood
we're currently sections
and where we will be seen an application
close by so I can read it in this
process this will match
um you could have been
my house
my area
everyone with the injections
that are listed widely with the lessons
foreign
both these developments the 1970s
that were built to the specs of the time
and there were an advantage
as of our residents with myself
the problem that we have here
is perception so
perception that you've heard into other
cases
every single one of the objections and
concerns has been and foreign
[Music]
the loss of residential community
created by Learners like this in an area
which has been effectively saved for us
is something you can't consider
that is actually the thing where you
want
why element that is new to me never be
mentioned in any of the other uh
objections to be alone so I guess
it was drainage
and as a result of my visits to this
site the conversations
I had a look at my own property
the provision of
utilities
Dreams water supply and telegram lines
gas on the police department and mine
is a little haphazard
and one of the concerns that and
mentions in the statement of my shield
is this extension will actually be deal
with
the requirements which will arise very
shortly
for the maintenance of those Human
Services
relative afterwards
and I've got somebody there isn't
received the perhaps
and one final one
of which one quite about rejection which
inevitable the rise of these sort of
extensions
those of you who are families of the
French storyline local salt
we remember
[Music]
the hell
in Little Brook
[Music]
hell is a little bit because of
extensions
that's where these concerns come from
and I hope that you can
see
the pure Technologies to give oh
somebody's religions
continue
but um
[Music]
so yeah
um
[Music]
yes
thank you chair uh again we'll watch the
transport uh
as a living space as well
um
number
30 multiplication numbers
gives an extension
and then the Ascension is good it
maintains out of the garage uh according
to 78 at the portions as well uh on the
street that will be advertising of it
and he's also use it slightly yeah
assign the improved book today
thank you chairman those are the kids
applications
[Music]
and I agree that Council Holden
absolutely that this is an absolute
perception
and that is often the case and I also
agree with cancer hold them that we have
the small owner's duty of making a
decision and then to a certain degree we
had to walk away from that scene and we
don't have to limit it often there's
heavier that makes it
UMC establish things because I thought
that that was eventually that I didn't
mean I didn't received
however in the terms of this application
I foreign
[Music]
um
foreign
production
indicates
uh
this application device is a rare
portion of the back problem of 13 Oxford
Drive
um the side points obviously on the road
to the Northeast
they have to explore language
series South and West Road
foreign
[Music]
position
significantly for the building line and
facility
as well as having an asexual courtesy
and over there some Canadian properties
the lhas furthermore requested that we
have to provide some another processor
outcomes
sexual access important position
Justice
and on this basis safety
particularly as any adverse hiring
practices
are the location is on sites and Coast
options to a school
the government Council does not
currently other five year housing not
supply
the sales departments have engaged the
economy would make the contribution of
one additional flying
Supply
prices
as such the applications
[Music]
to speak
to the professor
I I just like to talk about the research
group here as well just run between the
building line and under where it's
Portugal office
been approved to new buildable garages
which is very important and development
of this current application
in relation to the first walk by through
the window on Southeast Foundation I
take on board the council's observations
for loss of privacy
what we are willing to use complete
glass I would like to point out that way
about new objectives at any of the
Neighbors on yes
uh regarding the scale of height and
mass massive to
unproximity to compile this public
report so we point out that before
submitting any plans a personal
consulted with all the neighborhood
properties and received no objections
and this was a low level development
regarding satisfied and access to the
parking rail results I'd like to inform
you that we are right at around vehicles
to the real approximate brand which is
upper
for both sides under the herbicide
this will provide additional parking and
will have an additional access gate from
Foxwoods facilitate any additional
parking
and more than the two that's already
there depending on this should
satisfying objection
thank you
counselors
oh why
don't you see why not really
um
options
I'll get everybody else
[Music]
in relation to 24 of highways of
any Constitution made regarding uh
rejecting to me
not yet yeah
okay
and again the reason that what are the
basic concerns
isn't actually long enough
and SPD for states with their life for
the drive to actually
given the nature of the road
to disabled it
actually visibility is is
warming up
[Music]
um
yes
[Music]
uh
especially with the type of other
applications have been really
I genuinely cannot see that that would
form any candle over the government or
cramps and Congress uh
lots of landscape again I can't possibly
know what it is and as I say given
in terms of
objection number two
people
losing and that would almost wipe that
application that's objection
significantly we have other buildings
there are uh
it's not exactly uh yeah
[Music]
I agree with is
thank you
exactly
[Music]
business
become as only one parking space so I'm
just wondering if that is we can
literally have houses like that already
why are we only allowing
um houses to develop that have two two
car parking spaces
yeah yeah
foreign
[Music]
about
is
chat
on second Council Williams
[Music]
Port is extremely concise and I
appreciate that it's one sweet
[Music]
spot the people so
as well
I visited this stuff and I think this
development will be able to keep them
with our streets being down there
go against what comes to the ones
instead
um
well I'm saying the reasons to refuse or
not Circle I think that's a problem with
all that is completely other people
that's 18. so I talked about Google Maps
I've got it every screen he's looking
and we can see what shooting is quite a
curling
[Music]
at this location
then
I have concerns about what
um
those two cars
are rankings to each other
that would be dangerous it's not quite
simply lovely age
and the alkaline to life outside which
is walking down there
walking across from the left the driver
I will not be able to see nothing today
ask to pull up the reasons given by the
offices chairman that and
not really trading those reviews which
is a lot of work on his application and
I think that perhaps protect our
students perhaps is that the residence
of Oxford drives it or perhaps except
also we are on those boundaries
the distance is
objections the applicant said
we don't actually have been made we know
and
um
we look at each other's application as a
problem click on the checkbooks and we
still look at all the applications in
detail and then I support the offices
chair you can take away the reasons to
sample you are a reasonable answer and I
suppose
recommendation
thank you
thank you counselor I also visited
[Music]
or something
completely to follow appointments so the
second good order you proposal yeah
[Music]
against
because nationalism
our next question is
[Music]
Furniture
um
the application leads to a two-story
living attached property located on the
ashes
there are other Residential Properties
of Northwestern South monoxide please
the application has been referred to the
public Community is receiving six
representations consciously after
recommendations
thought for the direction of the first
four slide extensions single story rear
extension and other alterations to the
existing building
was refused on the 10th of December 2022
on the grounds of design and their
romantic concerns and potential
overlooking of the garden at 12
career at the property
objections from the neighbors to the
current application relate to a number
of issues including regular immunity and
residence Community concerns however the
post first law extension is
significantly small
under a different design for the fish
groups
in comparison with our previous
operation the first four expansion has
also been pulled away from the
boundaries with properties on algorithm
with the emission of the first Royal
Wedding window that was previously
proposed close to the family
[Music]
oh
um
[Music]
available
um
redesigned in this application
so let's consider exercise
conditions
today we have a statement to read
Housewives
[Music]
the festival extension is still
excessively large the same with the
original house and does not refer to us
that the architectural character of the
main house enable properties an overall
character in this area the width of
dispersible side extension looks out of
character dominant due to the size of
the rather than being subservient to the
original House planning policies side
attention is better over half of it
additional coming to individual house
that appears prominent in relation to
the original drawing and the council
will not look faintly on them
the proposed garage conversion and very
extension means external access between
current and where development would be
lost which would have a negative impact
on the emergency of residence the
application if approved will result in
an overdeveloped site with a
five-bedroom property this result in
increased number of cars and traffic in
a narrower County circuit as mentioned
in my previous objection there are
several good examples of first books
mentioned inside extensions on Ashford
and Elmwood where the real government
included a festival site extension which
is half of the original problem
things resulted in a good design balance
that caused council's fine policies and
respects the courage of the original
house this can easily be validated
temperature
[Music]
thank you chairman I think this is
this application
will work in the civilian factors
in the case I think however one of the
problems that we have is I think perhaps
similar to the 3D Drive application
there's a degree in the world has been
built as a result of the previous
application
[Music]
um
right
[Music]
um
I think possibly the only possible
um uh just yes I agree about 40 percent
I think the results generated by the
previous application
um
[Music]
that just is
on the agenda again on a few weeks
the next application for like 15
Evington Avenue it's Tuesday
[Music]
and no objections it's called committee
at the discussion at the head of
Plumbing it's an appropriate scale
masking and designs
Thomas
um
[Music]
in that case
contributions
[Music]
people
okay the application says planning
permission for eruption of an artificial
crash patient or like school and
Associates fencing fertilizing social
exam and he has funding areas in an
accident as well
facilities proposed to be used for
football but markings of various pitch
sizes enabling it to be used
we use a silver cell phones as well as
being available for use of our community
considerations
[Music]
so knowledge that there will be some
degree advantage of the Church of the
area and some potential validity impacts
on residential immediency however this
is investigated to a degree by the
nature of the site the presence of an
existing adjacent facility in the
distance of the facility to houses and
most public viewpoints
for a substantial sourcing benefits
associated with the provision of the
facility as the site sets out
comparatively within some limited
information the commission report of the
consultation response from England
additional information report sets out
the conclusion of Physicians regarding
drainage in the potential noise impacts
from The Proposal the hours of use of
the basic exhibitions to attemption
finish during the week in an 8 PM finish
on Saturdays Sundays bank holidays and
products
piercing any members who speaks
themselves investigations
foreign
[Music]
thank you
how's your business
um